on the mound today for the mets in game
one will be taiwan walker who pitched
really well in the home opener on
thursday boy he looked fantastic through
five innings
and he gets him and we have a fastball
walker strikes out mccutcheon to start
the day
after all those four seamers it looked
like that might have been a two-seamer
that's why you had all that run that ran
inside on mccutcheon and he couldn't
catch up with it
and he goes down swinging on that split
chain so walker making prodigious use of
that pitch early in the game
and he's got a couple of strikeouts
three two coming
and it's grounded weakly alonso's gonna
field it
walker's gonna cover and that retires
the side
one two three inning for taiwan walker
with a couple of punch outs mets come to
back no score
chase anderson loosening up out on the
mound for the phillies getting set to
face the mets for a second consecutive
game and dom smith for the vets and nemo
takes it low ball four and he's on base
yet again
seven walks already for nemo so one out
now dom smith who
accounted for the only two runs against
chase anderson when they faced him last
tuesday
nimo at first and one out and he gets
one of the air to right field hit pretty
well back on
smith strikes again he takes chase
anderson deep for a 2-1 homer
second of the year for dom both off
anderson and the mets of a quick
two-nothing lead
liner out to left-center field that's
going to split the gap and go to the
wall and boom
on his way to second base will be there
with a stand-up double
second double of the year for alec
and gregorius goes down swinging on the
splitter three strikeouts for walker
who's made
excellent use of that split change early
in this game
one one is hit out towards left dominic
smith is there makes the catch
bone tagging from third and he'll score
it'll be a sac fly for nab
it's a 2-1 ball game good situational
hitting andrew
well done due to coming to quinn and he
struck him out
walker fans quinn four strikeouts and
two innings for taiwan walker philly's
got to run back
let's lead two to one i wonder is it
harder to sweep
seven inning double header games as
gyorme banks one up the middle and he's
going to base it on the first pitch he
sees from anderson
so luis guillorme has picked up where he
left off last year he's now four for
seven to start the season
swing at a miss he does and he picked up
his first strikeout to get out
of the bottom of the second no runs one
hit and a man left in scoring position
we go to the third
it's two to one minutes
and he goes down swinging on the slider
five strikeouts first time through the
batting order for taiwan walker
as mccutchen goes down on strikes ten
batters
six strikeouts for taiwan walker who
struck out only four in six innings in
his first start
walker strikes out the side of the third
inning as he gets hoskins for the second
time
seven strikeouts over the first three
innings for taiwan
ball four through a 3-2 change-up and
ladora draws the lead off long second
one given up by anderson today
and a call strike three threw him a
changeup
second strikeout
toward the middle and right in his
kitchen that's his second 1-3
in the scorecard
line drive out toward right center field
that's it for a base hit boom stops at
second
well the phillies have first and second
with one out and again they do not play
him to hit the other way he does hit one
the other way mcneal is there to grab it
though and lenore with the turn and they
get the double play
side retired a little skimmer on the
ground for a 4-6-3 double play to get
walker through the top of the fourth
now the 3-1 pitch way outside ball four
and a two out walk for
guillory he's been on base both times
here today
swig of the miss and the inning is over
three strikeouts for anderson
who's allowed just the two runs through
the first four
70th pitch of the day today and that
fastball was in there for a call
strike three and nap knew it eight
strikeouts now for walker
the 3-2 it's high ball four he was not
swinging
with a fastball there and walker wasn't
really close with it so quinn
is a board goes
pitches outside ball four the phillies
have two on with one out
and andrew mccutchen is due up and now
walker's really got some trouble
and here comes louie and let's see if
luis rojas
has a move in mind with castro ready in
the bullpen
and mccutchen down on strikes castro
goes right back to the change
and mccutcheon strikes out for the third
time today two down
there goes quinn double steal throw to
third is high
and guillorme keeps it going
out but did he push him off the bag i
don't think he pushed him off the bag he
just
fell down and quinn went past the bag
so the mets get the third out of the
inning as quinn is caught stealing third
base umpire bruce dreckman makes the
call and not a peep out of the phillies
dugout quinn
was there on the bag giorme came down
and
it looked like quinn was trying to keep
going maybe he thought the ball was down
the line
let's get through the inning still up
two to one count three and one the
hoskins
all four that's three walks in the last
two innings for the phillies offense
and they have the lead off batter aboard
for just the second time
shoots it the other way that's a basin
into left field hoskins stops at second
phillies have two runners on with nobody
out
[Applause]
is that the thing of beauty oh two
coming
and deedy hits a ground ball mcneal has
to hurry in he'll get the out at second
and that's all
ball knight hit hard enough to turn two
so they force harper four to six for the
second out hoskins goes to third
gregorius at first with two down as
harper forced out
at second hoskins down to third base and
gene
segura coming up and a ground ball
softly to third
charging is guillaume he flips to first
not in time
the run scores and the phillies tie it
up at two
it's the hustle of gene segura that pays
off once again
how about it i think he lost another bat
but you know what
hey in the fight fields will take it
again the o2
and knapp goes down swinging two and the
inning
but not before the phillies scratch out
a run to tie it
two to two as we go to the bottom of the
sixth and they give them that's a chance
and they're final it back
and he strikes out ray and lupto to
start the top of the set
that's an even dozen strikeouts for med
pitchers today
[Applause]
now mccutcheon hits one out to right
chase and conforto back a couple of
strides
and diaz has a one two three top of the
seventh
and gourmet watches up high ball four he
finally threw his change up
did it on three and two and he missed
with it and the mets have got the
potential winning run aboard with nobody
out that was a good at baton
hit by a pitch and just like that the
potential winning run gets in the
scoring position
two and two swing and a miss he got it
with 96
riding up in the zone and the side is
retired
8th pitch of the at-bat coming and
hoskins goes down
swinging they came up and in with a
fastball and that's the first down in
the top of the 8th
you think about walking harper and
pitching the ball yes i do
i mean i would definitely do that have
already made that decision that's
exactly what they're going to do
with the runners on first and second the
go-ahead run is mccutchen
and off the glove of mccann and both
runners move up
medina hits it back toward the middle
spinning lindor's got it no player run
scores
and the phillies take a 3-2 lead
how about that the pass ball sets up the
go-ahead run
on just a soft spinning ground ball
off the bat of dd gregorius lindor is
the free runner
and pete alonso will be the batter but
the mets down by a run in the bottom of
the eighth inning playing in extra
innings in a seven inning game
and he drives that one base hit in the
left center lindora third is being waved
around
the throw by mccutcheon back to the
infield is off in the mix of time the
game
big hit pete alonso rbi single in the
bottom of the eighth and it's three to
three
and mccann hits one toward the middle of
the diamond gregorius knocks it down but
can't make the play
mcneil stops at third as segura
retrieves it
and the mints have the bases loading
three and two of the bases loaded
and bjorn hits one of the air to left
field
mcneil with the game-winning run and the
mets have won
the opening game of the double-header
jonathan biard with a walk-off hit
and the mets win it in eight innings
four to three